tell me a little bit about Sony and
Marvel coming together to do this and
why you guys were able to bridge that I
know you guys have known each other for
a long time
I think that we've been friends for a
long time we've been fellows spider-man
lovers for a long time and Kevin came to
me with a really fabulous idea and ideas
are everything
bringing spider-man into the universe
where he belongs as all the fans know
interacting with other characters for
the very first time and it was it seemed
like the right time to do it welcome
back everyone it's Charlie you all need
to say welcome back to spider-man
because he just came back into the MCU
as of last night that is right it is an
early Christmas Kevin Feige miracle will
break everything down how it all
happened why he was out of the MCU
whether or not they were just trying to
mislead us they were actually not
spider-man was legit out of the MCU for
the last month or so we'll do a new
round of the spider-man far from home
blu-ray giveaway just because of the
good news all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best
spider-man 3 theory on the video now
that Marvel is going to be making
spider-man 3 so I know you're all
shaking your heads in disbelief looking
at the headlines in your feed this
morning wait a minute is this true is
this an April Fool's Day joke no it is
not April Fool's here's the statement
from Kevin Feige this morning he says
I'm thrilled that spider-man's journey
in the MCU will continue and I and all
of us at Marvel Studios are very excited
that we get to keep working on it
spider-man is a powerful icon and a hero
whose story crosses all ages and
audiences around the globe he also
happens to be the only hero with a
superpower to cross cinematic universes
so and he goes on to say Sony continues
to develop their own Spidey verse you
never know what surprises the future
might hold
so what Kevin Feige statement means is
is that Marvel is gonna do spider-man 3
he'll appear in other non spider-man
solo films as part of the New Deal so
that means they'll come back for
Avengers 5 but he'll also appear in the
spider-man venom crossover that Sony is
working on with their spider-man films
so sony has venom 2 that they're getting
ready to shoot that
bee venom versus carnage with maybe a
tag a Spider Man at the end of that and
then Spider Man 3 the original plan that
Marvel had for that is that they were
gonna do Kraven the hunter and it was
going to be spider-man hunted because
everyone knows his secret identity so it
was gonna be all of the villains coming
for spider-man and now probably at the
end of spider-man 3 there would be some
sort of venom tag because Sony wanted to
do four films with Tom Holland and
Marvel is only doing spider-man 3 but it
sounds like Marvel and Sony are now on a
one at a time movie basis with their Co
financing deal Sony agreed to the terms
that Marvel stated in their original
offer remember all the stories from a
month ago when the deal fell apart and
everyone's like spider-man's out of the
MCU
well Sony actually agreed to the terms
that Marvel proposed during that initial
deal the way this deal reads is that
Disney and Marvel are gonna co-financed
25% of spider-man 3 for a 25% equity
stake that just means that they have the
potential to earn 25% of the box-office
profits when the movie comes out because
obviously the last spider-man far from
home film earned a billion dollars at
the box office that's way more money in
their pocket they also still hold the
merchandising rights on spider-man right
now spider-man 3 is officially scheduled
for release July 16 2021 I assume no
matter who was making the film even when
Sony said that okay the deal's off we're
gonna make spider-man 3 by ourselves
they would still try to release it July
2021 at some point this also confirms my
theory that Kevin Feige was secretly
talking about spider-man far from home
at his Comic Con Marvel phase 4
presentation without actually talking
about spider-man 4 if it's Secret Wars
or what like the space for start to
plant the seeds for whatever we're gonna
see because we obviously saw Thanos the
whole Infinity Saga the seeds were
planted way early on yes we debated what
we should announce today should we
announce four and five we've planned
them out we've got five years down the
road
and I was like I think you got 11
projects in two years is plenty because
at the time they had not resigned their
sharing arrangements so he couldn't put
it on the morrow phase for schedule so
spider-man 3 is officially now a Marvel
phase 4 schedule coming out sometime
around the same time as Marvel's what-if
series if it wasn't clear they're doing
23 episodes of that that means that
there are two spider-man episodes and
now three ostensibly when they do
another what-if season I know you got
burned so hard when spider-man left the
MC you're like wait a minute is this
real this sounds crazy what was going on
behind the scenes were they lying to us
this whole time were they actually
secretly making a deal and just trying
to drum up interest by getting people
excited the problem before was mostly
Sony's CEO in Sony Japan
getting involved with Kevin Feige bosses
at Disney so you just have a bunch of
business people at the top at both sides
at Disney and it's Sony and Sony Japan
just making alarmingly bad decisions
based on money alone so it sounds like
based on what they're reporting that
last night Kevin Feige in people who
actually understand the spider-man
character at Sony and Marvel got
together and sort of hammered out a new
deal if you remember Kevin Feige did
that interview of Tom Holland when they
said the spider-man was out of the MCU
he was not lying when he gave this
interview at this time spider-man was
genuinely out of the MCU I'm feeling
about spider-man gratitude and joy
basically we've made five great movies
it's been five amazing years I've had
the time of my life who knows what the
future holds but all I know is that I'm
gonna continue playing spider-man and
having the time of my life and it's
gonna be so fun however we choose to do
it and the future for spider-man will be
different but it will be equally as
awesome and amazing and we'll find new
ways to make it even cooler somehow we
got to make five spa films within the
MCU with spider-man and two standalone
films and three with the Avengers it was
a dream that I never thought would
happen it was never meant to last
forever we knew it was there was a
finite amount of time that we'd be able
to do this and we told the story we
wanted to tell and and I'll always be
thankful for that I know there are wild
conspiracy theories when anything like
this happens but Apple was never ago
- by Sony no.1 Amazon was never going to
buy Sony
so Spiderman until they hammered this
deal out last night was going to be out
of the MCU permanently until they came
back to the table it just turns out that
that happened last night as I'm posting
this video so now that spider-man is
back in the MCU we can talk about
spider-man three theories so obviously
they're going to continue with
everything they set up during spider-man
far from home
spider-man taking the mantle without
necessarily becoming the Next Iron Man
he can still keep those glasses with a
billion-dollar orbital weapons platform
there's not gonna be any huge plot holes
and because Sony is now developing a
Madame web movie for their spider-verse
that is sort of the key to spider-man
traveling the multiverse in explaining
how he can be in a venom movie venom
three maximum carnage whatever they want
to call that and still come back for
Avengers five but spider-man 3 is still
going to probably just be a single
villain movie and if Sony wants to do
their sinister six movie or their venom
crossover that would be spider-man 4 or
venom 3 they almost have a full sinister
six roster with the characters they've
already introduced so I would just
expect them to continue setting that up
in the background of spider-man 3 but
I'm not expecting Norman Osborn to be
the main villain of spider-man 3 or
anything like that what they're gonna do
now though is they're gonna lock down
their creative for spider-man 3 and
start working on that movie
so obviously Tom Holland all the people
from spider-man far from home are coming
back John watts is probably going to
direct they'll come up with an excuse
for him to pop up at the end of the
venom movie right now venom 2 seems like
it's going to be taking place in New
York City they don't necessarily have to
reference MCU stuff in venom 2 if they
want him to be in New York City you can
even just have spider-man just come show
up and deal with venom on his own
without them referencing other Avengers
stuff but it is important to note that
as part of this new sharing arrangement
that venom is not in the MCU is still
sort of its own thing so there will be a
little bending over backwards to explain
how other Avengers don't get involved
when venom starts stomping around New
York City right now I would think of it
in a spider-man homecoming situation
where the Avengers are dealing with more
cosmic threats the whole reason for
putting Nick Fury in outer space at the
end of spider-man far from home is to
let you know that the threats that
they're going to be facing in Marvel
phase 4 Marvel phase 5 well
way bigger way more cosmic than the
stuff that's happening on planet earth
most of that ground-level stuff will be
dealt with in those Marvel phase four
disney plus series like Captain America
Falcon Winter Soldier series were they
going after Baron Zemo very much in
earth-based series so everybody just
post all your theories about spider-man
3 and Avengers 5 with spider-man in the
comments below and to answer your
follow-up question what they'll probably
do after spider-man 3 in Avengers 5 is
that if Tom Holland wants to keep
playing the spider-man character so just
renegotiate a new spider-man sharing
arrangement to get him in other Avengers
movies like Avengers 6 obviously now
they can put him in Avengers secret Wars
they can give him the symbiote costume
during that just like the comics you
don't have to shoehorn giving spider-man
the symbiote in venom 2 or Ben in 3 or
anything like that I totally wasn't
expecting this to happen so fast it's an
early Christmas miracle there's other
Marvel videos that I'm working on -
there's a new Ghost Rider video that
I'll try to post as quickly as possible
but if you have any other big questions
about what's going on with spider-man
and how this all came together just
leave them in the comments below while
you wait for everything click here for
my deleted spider-man far from home post
credits scene with new footage and click
here for that Avengers infinity saga
trailer and Marvel phase 4 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
spider-man is back
[Music]